news stories predict a retirement crisis
of inadequate retirement savings in
response progressives have proposed
expanding Social Security benefits
establishing new retirement plans run by
state governments Americans are worried
in many pine for the days of traditional
pensions but the data tell a very
different story
far more Americans are saving in 401ks
today than ever had a traditional
pension contributions as a percentage of
salaries have risen by one quarter since
401k is introduced and total retirement
savings today are six times higher than
when 401k started IRS data show that the
typical retiree today as an income
higher than when he was working retirees
are half as likely to live in poverty as
working-age households and rather than
running out of money
the typical retirees network increases
as you gets older the real crisis is in
Social Security and state and local
government pensions which are
underfunded by up to 26 trillion dollars
sure 401ks need tweaks but I'll trust my
retirement the system is working not to
government-run plans that are short by
trillions what do you think about
retirement savings let us know in your
comments also let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from API